alright let me be very clear about
something I am NOT doing these every
week okay so the weather today is pretty
dry
I also meant in the office of eight
thirty nine and I then select way
possible Armand's currently ten so first
start of the week
my poor shoes they were built for this
kind of thing
[Music]
you know no that's the fungineer but I'm
pretty sure that's bad news for the
emergency life really saying that if
there's a fire and the emergency light
comes on that's going to cause a fire
[Music]
[Applause]
so my objectives for this week are
awesome right if you watch the previous
week in the life of a PhD video then
you'll know that I had an awful lot of
coding problems and I'm pleased to say
that we've got past those however
they've now been replaced by a
completely new set of even more
fundamental problems so this week I want
to try and solve some of those another
objective is to stop being such a little
[ __ ] and actually write some more of my
thesis I haven't written anything for a
little while and I do have plenty of
stuff to put in I just haven't got
around to doing it so I need to be a bit
more focused on that I also want to film
a video this week for my youtube channel
I want to do some more editing on this
big video project that I've been working
on for months and then there's a lot of
singing going on particularly this week
[Music]
like live streaming is so flirty
hey feelin there mate do you have a few
drinks last night not none at all nada
so today was frustrating I did get some
coding work done and sort of probed why
things were working where they weren't
working but I still can't make heads or
tails out of this new problem which is
basically that we can get our
temperatures now looking fine from the
code that I'm playing with but the
velocities totally wrong like
hilariously wrong also we got around one
of the problems we were having by code
cheating and splitting up our field into
a background state and anomalies which
is fine you're allowed to do that under
the maths but when we recombine them
makes no sense so I kind of raid quit at
one point and I switched it to a
different code I needed to run which is
going hopefully going to finish
overnight and then I was actually
getting some work done on a thesis so
I'm actually hitting one of my
objectives now though I am going to
start editing and hopefully get an early
night
[Music]
that was a great work I decided to
actually like writing my thesis because
I can write like all that's stopping me
from writing something my fingers on the
keyboard on the coves other things
anything can go wrong
plus I'm much better at writing I have
accounting so this lunchtime I'm doing
some rehearsal I mentioned that there
was going to be a lot of singing this
week so in addition to singing even some
tomorrow which every week there's also a
service on Sunday which I'm missing for
reasons that would come click and then
we're also giving production that
Handel's Messiah on Saturday so Handel's
Messiah might well be the greatest piece
of music ever written is this like
stonking great big huge oratorio it's
got lots of choir sections like you
definitely know at least one of them
[Music]
yep that's from this and there's also
these server sections called arias
Andres 'its and I've been asked to give
one of them so I am going to rehearsing
that and then as well as that I've also
been asked to death for the cathedral
console deafening is way basically fill
in for somebody Cathedral consort does a
couple of services a term I think at the
Cathedral at Exeter Cathedral so I am
singing for an even song on Friday
[Music]
confession I can't actually play the
game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so while the coding waves continue today
I actually smashed a key part of my
thesis like a really important thing
like three the crux I'm going to do
we're trying to introduce putting it
into words running some code to produce
some figures and some analysis that I
need to sort of quote figures to put in
the text and guess what I'm doing that
well guess what I'm doing now if you
guessed editing you were right so this
morning I was working on a little side
project to put my thesis which is
basically proving that one of the things
that we we proposed in our hypothesis is
equivalent to something that's already
used in the literature just slightly
differently framed now in order to do
that I've been using something called
empirical orthogonal function analysis
let me set that very British Li
orthogonal and in order to do this I had
to generate some data and like recast it
in a particular way and read the annuals
I couldn't leave the mean and I was
getting super frustrated because I wrote
the code in two halves one which did
that analysis like the repackaging the
data and then another half which did the
EOF stuff and the second half I was like
what this doesn't make any sense that
the data that I am getting out of this
data file is different from the data
they put into it what's going on and
then I realized that I've been saving
the data file the new versions to a
completely different folder so the data
that was reading in and the second half
was just really old like scrappy version
of it that I knew was wrong so that's
running over lunch now I'm back singing
we have eternal talk was he
[Music]
so I left script running in the office
now because I'm going off to Chapel and
it's looking really good like it's a
really important really important thing
to put in the thesis and basically it
was just a minus sign that was wrong oh
yeah in a plot so fingers crossed but
it's when I get back I'm gonna have
something that is really key done now
though it's time to sing even song with
Chapel Choir done mate
yes house Caro ah he's pretty good
thanks
Hugo yeah
how's co-rec it's wonderful I can't go
not good
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
okay so it's currently 8 o'clock and I
have been in the office - singing since
like 9:00 but I don't care because
things are going really really well let
me show you let me sing you in here so
one of the key things that we are doing
in the thesis is demonstrating that we
can capture the same kind of behavior in
using one index that we can with using
another so this is the index on the
y-axis that we're proposing to use and
on the x-axis the one that's
traditionally used and you can see
there's a really good correlation the
correlation is not point eight six
across the whole data set which means
that when one change is like in a
positive way one goes up the other one
goes up and you can see in the scatter
graph they're very similar and you can
also see in particular like a current so
this is just a hundred days of looking
at the data that are constructing index
at the bottom like I could basically
can't even tell them apart they're so
similar there's a little bit of banding
going on in ours that I still need to
have a look at but they basically
capture exactly the same behavior and
the real test for if this is doing its
job right is if the residuals of these
distributions are normal and the
scripture calculate that boom oh yeah
after month this isn't the main problem
code that I've been struggling with this
is something that um is like relatively
standard I just needed to write it but
it worked like something I coded
actually worked so let me just call out
my happy little faces this is going in
this bad boy there are definitely some
parts of my thesis that I need to
remember to take out before I hand it
all so the office is now empty because
it's a o'clock I can kind of show off my
it's like I have a little for now it's
kind of completely enclosed because we
moved the plan that's my peace lily
which had lost all its flowers because
somebody has got to water it when I was
away and they forgot to tell them to
water it might be my fault I've got my
laptop to run scripts on I've got my
computer which is meant to be running
scripts but I don't have some software
on it which I need so I can't really use
it but I'm using it to write the thesis
whilst I run code then I've got like
to-do list kind of things and things to
remind me and like ideas that I've had
and then over here I basically told
myself that until
I get the relaxation code working
properly I'm not going to throw out any
of the coke bottles or cans that I drink
for those wondering how I get through a
thesis without drinking coffee this is
how right next to work
[Music]
[Music]
okay that was a really long grind of a
day carrying on what I did yesterday
with the work improving those two things
are equivalent getting some figures
ready for my thesis and actually putting
them in it takes longer than you think
to get a thicker thesis ready anything
see yourself yeah that's good that's
enough it's a lot of time doing that and
writing actually pumping up that work
camp so it's getting on for half-past
six
I don't have enough time to actually get
any food before chapel choir rehearsal
tonight I may have actually stayed and
work a bit too long at the start the PhD
I definitely would just like leave early
because I don't have enough to do
now I'm getting towards the end of PhD
and finding myself staying too late
because I've got too much to do
if you're doing a PhD yourself and that
sounds familiar please let me know in
the comments because I that would it be
nice to know not the only one Addington
search in PubMed please be on time
please be empty are getting
you
[Music]
I swear to God if you can help it's so
great thank you guys
[Music]
snowmeow after rehearsals becomes the
perfect last night them do is kind of an
exception so I wanted to be working but
this is what we do
Godse trying to get a nice shot of the
Pope so today I had me to my supervisor
which normally we have every week last
time I made a video we didn't for some
reason and this meeting was the first
time we've kind of seriously talked
about who to get as my external examiner
my sick for my thesis which is marred ly
terrifying is in my head my examiner
that was terrified
[Music]
yes I'm really filmed today because I
kind of I just kind of lost focus like I
had those meeting before my meeting
which was a talk given by a friend of
mine who's just got her PhD on her
research then we had the supervision
then I had lunch and then I just kind of
didn't really get back into things now
I'm off to the cradle to sing some music
is quite hard I don't know very well
what could possibly go wrong
hi I'm here with the cathedral consort
you feeling comfortable you said you
were fine like a minute ago
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
we just got out you are right so that is
also Chapel fire and also joined us in
the Cathedral
how is the experience for you in the
cathedral yeah there's quite interesting
wearing a red Karthik trainer on you do
Cathedral for how many years
hi Winchester so it's kind of oh it's
basically old happened for me it was
first time I've ever done yeah it was my
feedback I lost me what's different
about singing in the Cathedral the
service now it's like slightly different
yeah true then the prayer that you
didn't do yeah I was just helping a lot
of another the Lord God what you gonna
do now that's what I asked it so I knew
I wanted to go and see fantastic beasts
tonight because I'm filming a video
about it this weekend however I forgot
that everybody I know is I was singing
another gig in the Cathedral tonight or
they're away so I'm just here on my
lonesome going to see a film definitely
not one I'm just chilling here my
friends excite for the film guys
[Music]
in your place I think so mom and dad are
in town for this portal Messiah which I
am at and aware about start rehearsing
dad and I had to take some couple to the
dump earlier which was exciting
Oh train train there's a train I didn't
know the train line went through there
well maybe not history she escaped
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damnit
how's it going so good it's great music
isn't having this many people yeah I've
been building some shaking well this is
inaccurate we just have like a three
hour rehearsal of the Alumni it's really
nice actually it was chatting to a bunch
of Illinois
and it's always great to talk to people
from previous whoopsie-daisy and it's
always great to talk to people from
previous generations of the choir you
know and find out what they've done you
just spectacularly walked into the shot
there sorry
don't keep that I won't well that's the
candles killed I've got some nice
background music from Imogen it's now
time for us to begin our performance and
cacica
[Music]
and we are done my voice is a little bit
shot I feel a bit like we crawled over
the finishing line because we've been
singing for we had like a three or four
hour rehearsal and then that's a
two-hour performance time and a lot of
that you're singing at the top of your
voice and top of the range as well so a
bit raggedy coming over the finish line
with the worthy is the lamb knee our men
everybody solos went pretty well I think
considering we had a weeks notice to
learn them I wasn't terribly pleased of
mine unfortunately my mouth what my
throat was too drier didn't bring any
water with me which is my fault
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
my mum said it was the most enjoyable
massage she's been to and she's been to
a lot because not because she's old
just because she's quite musically
active she's definitely gonna watch this
isn't she
not because right it's now time for
drinks so last night we managed to sleep
seven people in our house that is really
built for two people because I'm even
quite sure how you managed it honestly
there was I mean there was my girlfriend
and I my room and then in Dan's room
that it was like that scene in Charlie
the Chocolate Factory where they had
Grandpa Joe and all the other
grandparents in the Enlightenment bed
they were just like crammed in together
Daniel explain why your pillow is wet
because in a small room Stan we do
though anyway I needed a way we decided
to sleep for people instead of the one
that it normally is it a squeeze which
is not good shower the walls were
dripping as long as the windows with
with conversation so last night we went
to a house party after the Messiah and
one of the guys who lived there there
was a house belong to one of people in
choir we didn't really get along with
this guy he was being very loud and
obnoxious and he was just basically told
me to down a bottle of wine and I was
like no I'm not gonna do that and he
would walk you're not got any balls and
I'm gonna ask these guys to confirm that
this is what happened I just basically I
stood up right next to and I was like me
I don't conform it to your notion of
masculinity did that happen very much
did yeah and then he Vicki was just like
uh-uh
and then left the room too many words of
processable yeah but I just I wanted it
to be on record because this sounds like
when they're stories like yeah and I
stood up and I was like yeah well I like
hospital food it was basically like you
know I mean kind of dr. Mitch
documentaries you see the strutting
peacock sorry
he reminded me a bit from Back to the
Future it's just such a dick just such a
dick for once the guy with the words and
not all the muscles yeah one guys
so this road was meant to have inspired
Diagon Alley because JK Rowling when
Cheney here so a back in the house we're
joined by Lily he was starting the last
vlog you do your time yet the time years
yeah exactly
and Dan's over here in the corner we
were going to be recording a video we've
got all the paraphernalia here but we're
all too too hung over from last night to
make a decent video so maybe a couple of
weeks and then we'll get you buddy back
uh like a bag of smashed crabs like a
stunt man's knee yeah not not feeling
the best so this week's been a pretty
interesting mix of things but the most
interesting is yet to come
alright like at a singles West raffle
this
so I'm flying to Belfast and I'm flying
to Northern Ireland to film some videos
oh let's go looking for someone right
now I can tell you that these videos are
educational and they are not going on my
channel but I can tell you who they're
for or when they're coming out I will
have of Yves logging all of next week
and I'm going to put that vlog out when
I'm allowed to post it by the people who
are hosting the videos it's very
exciting I've never been to Northern
Ireland before so yeah
at any rate thank you very much for
watching this vlog people really like
the first one so if you enjoyed this
second week in a life then do like leave
a comment down there so I'm lying on the
bed so I kind of want to be like down
there so do leave a comment down there
and leave like if you liked it I quite
like doing these so if you want more I
can do more maybe not every week
[Music]